ready here we go
my customers aren't interested in
iphones or ipods they're interested in
their memories where they were able to
dance and sing to a jukebox it's all
about making people happy
my name is perry and i'm the owner of
perry's jukebox and pinball repair
company in brooklyn my business is one
of the few businesses in the country
that's capable of repairing vintage
jukeboxes these are called vacuum tubes
in most cases half of them are good half
of them are not good ever since i was
child i was always interested in motors
fans and things that moved
and looking at a jukebox the arm the
turntable the spinning and the motion
was something that i was very intrigued
by
i do around 20 house calls a month to
repair jukeboxes i've been asked to go
to ireland tasmania thailand and
scotland through the correct settings
tube is no good
most people that call me they love their
machines they have the uh records in
them from when they were teenagers and
it brings back memories and they think
that they're never going to work again
no this one's more promising look at
this
being able to uh restore the machine
it's something that really makes me feel
good i always leave a house with music
playing
you